so one time we were going out to eat and
this [__] lightweight got on my nerves a
little bit because she
lives
no it's not I was
not okay so literally the bill comes out
right she goes don't worry I got this
one I'm like okay cool I'm watching this
girl go through molasses trying to find
this card I've never seen somebody move
so slow in my life to pick up a bill
she's just like look this is the card by
the way let me just show you okay eight
hours later
I wonder where my card is I'm sitting
here watching this by the time she finds
a card I already gave my card they came
back oh my God such a liar I was just I
don't know why
so slowly maybe that's what you were
saying you're like